[Music]
this is what the people of Lebanon have
feared a violent turn for what has been
for days a popular mostly peaceful
uprising
[Music]
the world credits birdie made off with
pulling off the biggest Ponzi scheme in
history but that is just a flat out lie
because the biggest P scheme in the
history of humanity actually goes to
Lebanon yes the tiny country of Lebanon
just above Israel is responsible for the
biggest financial fraud of all time and
it's not just us saying it it's the
World Bank saying it and in 2019 that
Ponzi scheme
collapsed there is a shortage of US
dollars in the Lebanese Market it's
causing a crisis the closed doors a sign
of a deep unresolved economic
crisis
[Applause]
[Music]
came
nearly eight in 10 people in Lebanon are
now poor nearly half of the workforce is
unemployed Lebanon is in the grip of a
massive economic crisis the economic
crisis the media covered this as just
another Financial meltdown of a poor
country due to government mismanagement
nothing special but in reality the
political Mafia of Lebanon knew exactly
what they were
doing this wasn't just Reckless
mismanagement no this was a coldly
calculated scam designed to attract as
much money into Lebanese Banks as
possible they offered insanely High
interest rates they pitched Lebanese
Banks as safe they pitched Lebanon as a
Switzerland of the Middle East when in
reality they were systematically moving
every last dollar of the people's money
into their own pockets how much money
you ask well our guy Bernie made off
with around $65 billion very cute while
the masterminds behind lebanon's poszi
scheme they made off with an insane $115
billion and that's just depositor money
they also Shackled the country in $100
billion in debt and they made off with
practically all that money too which
brings this stuff to over $215 billion
numbers that Bernie could only dream of
and the best part is that Berne got 150
years in prison while our Lebanese
perpetrators they're still living a life
of luxury in Lebanon armed security
guards and all to this very day while
the people of Lebanon watch their
savings get wiped out at the flick of a
wrist and if you're watching this and
you're not Lebanese and you're wondering
why you should care about this well what
you're about to see the calculated fraud
the grift the wiping out of people's
entire life savings the transfer of
wealth from the poor and the middle
class to the elite all of this is only
possible when you have Fiat money and
Central Banking which means all this
chaos is just a light preview of what is
to come for America and the world in
just the next few years because new
slash is not just Lebanon that operates
like a Ponzi scheme I visited Lebanon 2
weeks before the recent conflict broke
out in the region I love the place and
there I met alas Allah is one of the top
political activists in Lebanon he's
helped to elect multiple people into
office as fighting for actual change and
he explained this entire Pon schem to me
while I was in Lebanon and when I heard
just how incredibly genius the scheme
was I knew we had to make a documentary
on it his info will be linked below if
you're Lebanese even if you don't live
in Lebanon share this video with your
Lebanese brothers and sisters to help
get the truth out so two the people of
Lebanon stay dangerous this is
definitely one of my favorite videos
we've ever made and let's get into
it this is what the people of Lebanon
have feared shut for much of the day by
just enough force and
intimidation we've seen from some
political
C
who what you're about to see in this
video is a preview of what is to come
for America because guess what the
American banking system is just as much
of a Ponzi scheme as Lebanon the only
difference is that America has the
muscle to keep this Ponzi scheme of
floats but that could all soon be
changing trust in the dollar is at an
all-time low the FED is going to have to
turn the money printer back on again
soon or else we're going to have a
depression countries all over are
already ditching the dollar the interest
on us de has just passed a cool1
trillion so it really does look like the
dollar might be on its last leg so if
you don't want your life savings to be
decimated by failing Banks or currency
Wars now is the time to call one of the
most trusted precious metal dealers out
there American Hartford gold they'll
show you how to protect your savings and
retirement accounts by diversifying your
wealth portfolio with physical gold and
silver with the finest products amazing
customer service and a buyback
commitment American Harford go has a
five-star rating from thousands of
reviews and an A+ from the Better
Business Bureau and what's great is that
they support content like this that's
committed to bringing you the truth tell
them I sent you and they'll give you up
to $5,000 of free silver on your first
order so call them now click the link
below or call 86667 1 4392 that's 866
671 4392 or text TR to 65532 again
that's 866 671 4392 or text Trend to
65532 thanks to them for sponsoring this
[Music]
video we have to get to the barach
now get down
man the origins of this Pony scheme can
be traced back to the Lebanon Civil War
that started in 1975
it was absolutely brutal over the next
15 years fighting between a long list of
political and religious factions would
lead to more than 2,000 deaths and
nearly a million that would be displaced
one of the reasons the war was so brutal
is because there weren't just two sides
to it instead it involved a lot of
different groups fighting against each
other and each of these factions were
led by a warlord but not the type of
warlord you're probably thinking of
right now in Lebanon a warlord can be a
politician a businessman or a government
official that offer protection to his
district or Community but in exchange
for his protection his people would have
to support and fight for him their power
was Often bolstered by external support
and the collapse of central Authority
during the Civil War these leaders were
seen both as protectors and as
opportunists capitalizing on the chaos
for personal or communal gain and in
these 15 years of fighting these
Warlords would become super rich
powerful and influential many of them
were supported by foreign countries like
Syria and Iran who had interest in
Lebanon so there was always money
pouring in for weapons and equipment
money that could be siphoned off for
their own personal gain but in 1990 the
war ended and a new democratic
government was being established so
suddenly for the Warlords all that power
and wealth they have been enjoying for
the last 15 years was under threat the
money stop flowing in for their
International backers without a war why
would their people need their protection
anymore but luckily for the Warlords
they did have something going for them
see the war had plunged most of Lebanon
into poverty the people needed jobs they
needed basic necessities like running
water and so on basic necessities that
were going to be controlled by this new
incoming government so to keep their
Gras on the people the Warlords that the
only thing they could they got into
public office so what was the answer the
answer was let's get them into the
public sector now in peace time the same
warlord are the ones who have the ticket
for their followers to the public sector
job to the hospital to the school they
even control judiciary they control who
gets into the public sector into Army
into security agencies and so on so
that's a warlord in Lebanon he's like a
goddess more or less all these Warlords
from the Lebanese Civil War ended up in
all the High Wrecking government
positions and from these positions they
could offer their followers jobs safety
basic services like running water in
schools but only if their followers kept
supporting them only if their followers
kept them in office so even though
Lebanon would look like a democ y from
the outside if you didn't support your
local warlord you would suddenly find
yourself without a job your kids's
future would be under threats and your
business could be shut down for no
reason at all and there's actually a
name for this type of political system
it is known as a clientelistic political
economy where if you want the basic
necessities of life well you better keep
voting for me and so the Warlords filled
the ranks of lebanon's newly established
governments they were able to hang on to
their power but they still had to solve
the money problem after all what is
power without money the only issue was
the Lebanese government didn't have any
money to begin with the country had just
gone through a long brutal War they
didn't have any cash they didn't have a
functioning economy and so the political
Elite of Lebanon these Warlords got
together and concocted a plan and it all
centered around a guy named Riyad
salemma in 1993 lebanon's primee
Minister appointed Riyad Salma as
governor of Lebanon Central Bank but
Riyad wasn't just some old politician or
warlord oh no no no he was a banker and
before taking over the Central Bank of
Lebanon he was an executive manager at
Meo Lynch and as the governor of the
Central Bank of Lebanon he would be the
Mastermind behind turning the entire
country's banking system into the
greatest py scheme in the history of
mankind as the man in charge of the
Central Bank Riyad Salma had his work
cut out for him after 15 years of war
most of Lebanon needed to be rebuilt but
luckily Riad understood exactly how to
get for loans foreign loans from
International banking institutions that
just love sinking their teeth into poor
War Tor countries International banking
institutions like the World Bank the
international monetary fund and other
large foreign investors so with the
government's help Riad painted the
perfect picture of Lebanon for these
International Bankers first he pecked
the Lebanese L at 1,500 L per US dollar
meaning that no matter what would happen
the Lebanese government guaranteed that
1,500 L could always be exchanged for $1
no more no less this is very attracted
to foreign investors it meant you could
park your money in Lebanon and not have
to worry about the currency going down
in value and it made Lebanon appear like
one of the safest places in the world to
park your money this stability convinced
the IMF and foreign investors to start
pouring foreign currency and Aid into
the country their thinking was this is a
war torn country with the right
Financial Foundation if we invest money
into them we will be getting in on this
investment at the very floor which means
we're basically getting a guaranteed
return as the country rebuilds as long
as the money is used well
and so foreign big money started pouring
in and for a short while it looked like
it was working see Lebanon is an
extremely beautiful country with a rich
history and thanks to all these new
Investments and Loans the country was
getting the Warlords were able to siphon
off some of that money into their own
Pockets while at the same time within a
few years the country really did
transform into the premier tourist
destination in the Middle East tourists
all over the world were flocking to
Lebanon and bringing their dollars and
Euros with them even better the millions
of Lebanese citizens displaced by war or
born overseas would regularly send their
dollars and Euros back home to their
families so there was no shortage of
foreign currency that the government
could Tax Lebanon really was looking
like a middle eastern miracle in the
eyes of foreign investors but our
Central Banker Riad didn't stop there
see with every py scheme you need an
insane investment to pitch for Bernie
maid off it was his investment firm that
was giving his investors impossible
returns but for lebanon's py scheme it
would be their Banks giving depositors
impossible returns it started off with
Riot allowing local banks to offer the
depositors almost 8% in interest that
means anyone can open up a bank account
in Lebanon deposit some money and
magically receive 8% a year 8% was
already insane and that was going all
fine and dandy the banks were happy the
Warlords were happy they were skimming
money off the top and the depositors
were aesthetic but then the Arab Spring
came about MTI he is not the Prime
Minister but some Harari supporters are
refusing to accept such a deal nazin
sadri
I'll
[Applause]
in 2011 massive protest uprisings and
revolutions spread throughout the Middle
East in what would become known as the
Arab Spring and Lebanon was no exception
the Arab Spring sent foreign investors
and tourists running for the hills
foreign aid money was getting redirected
to Syria for their Civil War So within
the space of a few weeks Lebanon was in
deep trouble financially so our Central
Banker Riyad Salama did the only thing
he could to keep the grift going he
turned up the pzi schema
[Music]
Notch to keep his scheme going Riad
allowed local Lebanese Banks to buy
treasuries with interest rates of up to
40% a year think of treasuries as like
you're loaning the government money in
exchange for a fixed interest rates for
example if you loan the American
government money by buying American
treasuries you would get a sad return of
around just 5% a year the Lebanese
Central Bank was offering 40% 40% a year
is unheard of these are the kind of Gams
people look for in crypto and yet this
was coming from a small country that
produces nothing and solely operates off
of Tourism the lebanes central bank was
basically saying that hey our economy is
going to explode so fast that we can
guarantee you a return of 40% a year
which meant that local Lebanese Banks
can literally double their money in less
than 3 years just by buying treasuries
how is this possible who knows but who
cares if it's too good to be true the
Central Bank of Lebanon the miracle of
the Middle East was making this offer it
had to be legit I mean there was no way
the central bank would risk bankruptcy
and wiping out their entire country's
economy just to offer good interest
rates right the opportunity was just too
good to pass up but there was only one
catch these treasuries could only be
bought with foreign currencies dollars
Euros pounds the Central Bank didn't
want any of their own Lebanese L that
they knew were BS so the Lebanese Banks
bought into it the local banks took all
of their depositors money and poured it
all into leban Leese treasuries the more
treasuries they bought the more money
the Lebanese Banks let to make no one
cared to ask how this was even possible
all the local banks saw was that sweet
40% return on their money and nothing
else sure some banks may have been
skeptical but when that first year
passed and that 40% interest actually
showed up in their accounts there was no
turning
back
with that 40% interest in hand Lebanese
Banks were able to offer depositors up
to 10% interest that was if you
deposited foreign currency like the
dollar if you deposited Lebanese Lera
you would get as high as 15% and since
the Lera was pecked at the dollar there
was no risk to show you how insane 10 to
15% returns are on Bank deposits the
stock market returns an average of 10%
and that 10% is far from guaranteed on
America if we can get 4 to 5% on a high
you savings account when rates are high
like they are right now that is
considered amazing already while Lebanon
was offering double to Triple that for a
country that again produces nothing but
tourism so money started flowing into
Lebanese Banks like never before they
started to attract like small amount of
money like a Lebanese uh guy who want to
work in Dubai and who has like few
hundreds of thousands of dollars so by
giving this much of an interest those
people started to send their money and
putting them in leane Banks for this
High uh interest rate and some people in
Lebanon you'll be surprised like middle
class people they sold their houses and
put their money in the banks in return
for the interest rate so they attracted
different wallets in different phases of
the economy people viewed the Lebanese
Banks as uh save Haven because like the
law in Lebanon ensures uh banking uh
secrecy on on your accounts this is
first second they Market it as the uh
the Switzerland of the Middle East third
thing is they attracted money not only
from the Lebanese diaspora they
attracted money from uh the gulf which
is uh the oil money and especially when
the uh the oil uh prices were very high
they attracted money uh for political uh
political money from Gulf countries they
attracted money after this Syrian war
from Syrian politicians they attracted
money from Iraq and they attracted money
from Libya after the Libya Libya's War
so they attracted like tons of money on
the surface it looked like Lebanon had
cracked the Cod to unlimited wealth and
everyone wanted a piece of the action
but in reality the Lebanese people were
in for a brutal
surprise there were orders to move them
on and they tried
among the group here being pulled back
by an officer was Zade
said as the Lebanese people saw the
number in their bank accounts magically
keep Rising behind closed doors the
exact opposite was happening all that
money would just flow from the
depositors to the local banks to the
central bank which would then get
divided up amongst the Warlords that
money would fund their lavish Lifestyles
and it would also go towards paying off
their underlings and supporters but even
that wasn't enough remember how we said
Riad salaman made Lebanon attracted to
International Bankers like the IMF and
World Bank well on top of this PCY
scheme they were also taking on massive
loans from these institutions as well
they took these loans under the guise of
foreign aid and investing into the
growth of Lebanon when in reality it was
also to enrich themselves they grew that
from 1 billion to more than 11 billion
in like course of uh 8 n years this de
was from uh from International Banks and
international institutions so all the
debt is the 100 billion debt part of it
is internal debt debt from commercial
Banks which is in exchange for Euro
bonds so the commercial Banks lend the
central bank money in exchange for EUR
bonds and some of the debt is external
debt from International institutions and
so on but at time 2019 world around the
elite have forced the country into over
$1 billion in debts and all that debt
all that foreign aid we're sure that
maybe a few L eventually made their way
into public projects for the people but
most of it went straight into the hands
of the Warlords and their underlings
$100 billion on top of the $15 billion
from depositors Riyad Salma and his
warlord buddies had pulled off the theft
of a century and it was working
shockingly well but then the crack
started to
[Music]
show in 2019 all those fake returns
finally caught up with the Lebanese
governments all it took was for foreign
investments and treasury bond sales to
slow down just a tiny bit and suddenly
things started going very wrong so
starting 2019 the Lebanese L rate was
starting to be a bit different than what
it was before than the 1,500 Lebanese
pound for pack each dollar but not
officially so the official rate remained
1,500 L but in Black markets it was like
1,600 1,700 so people started to notice
something unusual happening this is one
the second thing people started noticing
that when when you are going to to the
bank and telling them I want $30,000
from my account to buy a car they ask
you too many questions and they tell you
go and come back after a week when you
go and ask them I want to send $50,000
to my uh daughter who is studying in
London let's say they will tell you we
can't send it at one time we need to
send it like in different batches go and
come back after a week or something when
you go and you tell them I want $100,000
from my account to buy something they
ask you too many questions and they tell
you keep it we give you more interest on
it don't invest it don't do this and
that so they start to give you advices
against giving you your money so people
started to worry and that's when people
started to worry about their money the
banks started to kind of freak out
around the situation more than 40% of
the banks are owned by the politicians
who are in the government spending the
money who controlled the central bank as
words spread that the banks probably
don't have enough money in the vaults it
started a classic bankr run and so the
government limited withdrawals all of a
sudden if you had $100,000 in your
accounts the bank would only offer you
$30,000 to close your account and the
longer you waited the smaller that
number would get it was either you
swallow your pride and get some of your
money back or you would be left with
nothing and when no one depositing any
more money in foreign investment scar
away the government needed more money so
they made the only logical decision
raise taxes on the middle class and poor
people while the elite they were
completely unaffected most of them had
already moved all their stoling money
offshore where it was safe and sound and
then came the final straw on October 17
2019 the Lebanese government in all its
Infinite Wisdom announced a brand new
tax on using Whatsapp like most of the
world WhatsApp is the main messenger app
in Lebanon it's what most people use to
keep in touch with their family abroad
and to avoid paying for expensive
international calls now the government
was planning on charging them another $6
a month just to use the app the Lebanese
people had had
[Music]
enough
with the Ponzi scheme collapsing and
financial armag getting underway one of
the first things to collapse was the L
to US dollar peg in November 2019 after
more than 20 years of sticking to the
1,00 L per dollar Peg the Lebanese L was
officially devalued but that was just
the beginning of it over the next 4
years the L's value will fall to more
than 100,000 L per dollar on the black
markets imagine your savings going from
1,500 L per dollar to 100,000 l per
dollar inflation were RIS by more than
170% people who used to earn the
equivalent of $1,000 in Lura were now
earning less than $100 a month for many
people especially the middle class this
2019 collapse LED them into poverty
because they have numbers in banks of
savings and they managed and organized
their Lifestyles around a reality which
happened to be an illusion due to this
collapse due to the Ponzi scheme this is
one second many of the citizens as I
mentioned before were public sector
employees in a way or another teachers
Army security agencies Judiciary public
sector agencies you name it those they
get paid in Lebanese L and not only they
get paid in Lebanese L their savings and
their pension plan is in Lebanese l so
the value of their savings was
demolished we trade so much of our lives
for money so to steal a working man's
money is to steal a portion of his life
you were partially murdering him and
that is what the Warlords and political
Elite of Lebanon did to the very own
people in fact that is what's always
happening when governments print money
or attx you too much everyone that had L
everyone that had money in the bank they
were practically completely wiped out
the only people that somewhat benefited
were those that had debt denoted in L
like a mortgage or whatever
hyperinflation gave them a real good
discounts those in Lebanon that mainly
earned their money in foreign currency
like dollars were mostly unaffected if
their money wasn't in local banks but
the vast majority of people the poor the
service workers the government employees
the middle class that saved their entire
lives they were thrown into
poverty I used to buy three or four
kilos of tomatoes now it's one or even
half a kilo everything changed I can't
afford meat or chicken we are only
buying
Essentials the Central Bank tells us
that the W devue but the economy is bad
people barely can afford to
eat if the economic situation continues
the way it is then the lero will really
be in danger we need a government to
deal with the crisis it got so bad that
people were even robbing banks to steal
back their own
[Music]
money
you said they didn't get in trouble no
because by law it's your own money they
only get in trouble for using Force for
doing things that by lawy are not
allowed to do but they don't get into
trouble as robberies when I visited
Lebanon we exchanged $200 for Lebanese L
this is one of the stacks I got each one
of these bills is $100,000 L my friend
told me to treat each one of these
100,000 L bills as around $1 and every
place you went like restaurant or
whatever you can pay in whatever you
want L dollars or Euros one Witter told
me that you can pay in L dollars Euros
gold bars we will take anything here
that is what happens when everyone loses
faith in the currency by the time the
dust settled the people wanted names
they wanted to know exactly who was
responsible for destroying their lives
and as it turns out it wasn't hard to
figure
out
[Applause]
in October 2021 2 years after the Ponzi
scheme collapsed nearly 12,000 leaked
documents were published online known as
the Pandora papers these documents
contain the details of hundreds of
offshore accounts that powerful people
used to hide their money most people on
the list did it because they didn't want
to pay taxes a noble Pursuit but not
everyone on the list was like that one
of the people exposed in the leak was
our good old pal Riyad salame as it
turns out Riyad Salam had a long list of
offshore accounts it was revealed that
Riot has stashed hundreds of millions of
dollars in accounts belonging to himself
his brother and his son $300 million to
be exact where did a central bank
Governor get his hands on a quarter of a
billion dollars wasn't he supposed to
get a basic salary like all the other
people in public office well according
to Riyad he was already worth $23
million way back in 1993 long before he
was appointed Governor but that begs the
question how did he manage to turn $23
million into more than 300 million
without any business of his own either
he was the Oracle of beu or the man
responsible for orchestrating the misery
of the Lebanese people and that $300
million was probably just a tip of the
iceberg for all we know this Central
Baker could very well be a billionaire
not bad for a public servant when you
agree and oh what a surprise lebanon's
then prime minister najib Madi and
former prime minister Hassan diab were
also implicated in the Pandora papers
the people wanted these criminals to
face justice but let's be real that was
never going to happen you can't him he
has more than 100 bodyguards he's in
Lebanon and protected by the same ruling
class with a huge mansion with tens of
security guards private security guards
Lebanese Judiciary issed a warrant
against him to protect him from going to
the French Judiciary because the
Europeans are going after him and they
came here to interrogate him and he he
refused to attend one session of the
interrogation he's been refusing and he
didn't go and the ranese government
didn't interrogate him they issued a
warrant against him to protect him so in
theory they issued a warrant that they
want to arrest him but in practice they
didn't like every time they issue that a
special security Force went to his house
but they didn't find
him while the vote kept most of the old
God in power 12 new independent emps
made it through naat AA and her
four years after the crisis and Lebanon
is still feeling its effects and it's
only going to get worse if this war
escalates no electricity more than 3 4
hours in some areas in Lebanon so people
they have to find alternative either to
pay fresh dollars for a solar panel or
or for a private generator or to buy
their own generator or they have to live
without any electricity without any
light in their house things will not
change without serious political reforms
so without being engaged in this
Workshop in this effort to to change the
political scene things will not change
so for all Lebanese people in Lebanon
and outside Lebanon this ruling class is
dangerous on us and on coming
Generations so it's vital to mobilize
and organize ourselves in Lebanon and in
the diaspora to change this ruling class
for things to change everyone has a role
to play either Lebanese people in
Lebanon or Lebanese people in the
diaspora so Lebanon is is going to to
face hard times that needs the
mobilization of International Community
that needs to the mobilization of its
own internal organizations in the
private sector in the public sector and
in international organizations working
in Lebanon and local organizations to
work together towards one goal to
prevent this country from SL slipping
into worst phases of the collapse if
you're not Lebanese and you want to help
one of the most important things is to
make sure your money ends up in the
right hands International organizations
and International Community uh must be
working and opening opportunity for
local organizations working with trusted
local organizations and not working with
governmental entities and Ministries
because for the past years those
Ministries those governmental entities
have been abusing this money the third
thing is to mobilize more funds for the
support of this country because it
really needs it and I know that there
are many other countries in need and
many other emerging priorities from
Ukraine to other countries but it's a
hard situation in Lebanon and it needs
the solidarity of of the world being an
agent for change I ran for parliamentary
elections in 2022 and I was one of the
organizers of 2019 protests and I wrote
a chapter in the lebanon's uprising book
authored by remma Majid and Jeffrey
Karam you can like find it and uh read
the chapter I I wrote on my experience
uh during the uprising during the 2022
elections I proposed a Clear Vision and
reforms towards a secular just and
Democratic Lebanon it's also available
online and people can check it out we'll
link to Allah's info below but wait the
story is not over yet because all of
this still begs the question isn't all
Central Banking around the world also a
giant py
scheme and all of this the banking
collapse the hyperinflation the transfer
of wealth from the middle class D the
elite this is almost exactly what's
going to happen in America when the
American Ponzi scheme breaks we can all
feel it in the air the stubborn
inflation The Reckless leaders the
coming Wars The Perfect Storm is brewing
but since the American economy is at the
center of the world when America
collapses everyone around the world will
be impacted and guess what this perfect
storm was all predicted in an old book
written almost 30 years ago called the
fourth turning in this book what the
authors discovered is that history
literally repeats itself in 80 to 100
Year Cycles which is around the length
of one human lifetime each of these
Cycles contains four parts four turnings
of around 20 years each the first of
these turnings is called the high an
upbeat era that happens right after a
giant crisis usually a big war then
comes the Awakening then the unraveling
and then the crisis the last crisis we
had was World War II the crisis before
that was the Civil War and the crisis
before that was the Revolutionary War
and so on and so on and oh would you
look at that all these crisis are
magically 80 to 100 years apart and
these 80 to 100 years Cycles don't
happen because of some Grand conspiracy
now they they happen because of simple
predictable human behavior one
generation builds the Next Generation
tears it all down and the final
generation has to suffer through a giant
crisis and you know what that means
right that final generation is us and
we're due for the next Crisis in just a
few years just as Destiny intended which
means with the dollar weakening with the
FED out of options to fight inflation
with the interest payments on US debt
already surpassing a trillion dollar a
year would Janet Yellen saying we can
quote certainly afford two Wars with the
wealth gap between the rich and the poor
continue to widen all of this is
supposed to happen and the next few
years are just going to get a whole lot
worse so if you and your loved ones
don't want to get absolutely crushed
along with the rest of the masses you
better start preparing right now and to
help you prepare and navigate this
crisis I'm going to be hosting a brand
new free three-part documentary series
called the crisis that will be dropping
on November 26th of this month we're
going to be peeling back the curtains on
the cycles of history we're going to be
going over what this coming crisis will
potentially look like we're going to be
going over who will be the winners and
losers and most importantly we're going
to make sure you come out on top to join
this drop again it's free all you have
to do is scroll down and click the link
below and sign up what your name and
email it takes 11 seconds once you're in
we'll give you everything you need to
know once the series is ready so you can
be the first to watch the cycles of
history tell us that everything is about
to change now whether or not it
collapses For Better or Worse is to be
determined but the fact of the matter is
this really is our last chance to
prepare before the entire economic
system as we know it changes forever but
the good news is that we have time to
prepare it together because just like
you I do not feel ready for this either
I'm still preparing so November 26th the
crisis mark your calendars and click the
card on the screen or click the link
below to join this drop
[Music]
now